ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. HURRY ARAMBULA
OUR QUE HAN IN IT BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH
BONTA BURKE CALDERON CORREO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALY
DALY DAVIES FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN. APRIL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KILEY LACKEY LEE LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN WHEN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON. THE NORRIS
QUIRK QUIRK SILVA RAMOS RAY IS
LOOSE REBAJAS ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
SAY ARTURO SMITH STONE TEAM
CALAVERAS BE APPROVED BY A
VOEPEL. WALDRON WARD WICKS WORD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN IMAM YES THEY ARE CON
YOU MONEY IS HERE. IN THE NAME
OF GOD. THE MOST GRACIOUS THE
MOST MERCIFUL. I'M NOT A GUARD.
YOU HAVE BROUGHT US TOGETHER ON
THIS FLOOR. HELP US AS WE
STRUGGLE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
OUR STATE. TO MEET ONE ANOTHER
WITHOUT BITTERNESS. I'M TO WORK
TOGETHER WITH MUTUAL
FORBEARANCE AND RESPECT. MAKE
IT SO THAT THE BARRIERS THAT
DIVIDE US MAY CRUMBLE. SIX
MISSIONS DISAPPEAR AND HATREDS
SHE'S. MAY WE LIVE IN JUSTICE
AND PEACE I MEAN. THANK YOUR
MOM YES HERE WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE. PLEASE JOIN ME READY
BEGIN I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE. THE
NEW YORK. ZERO AND. NUMBER ALL
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
MOVING THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL SOME
GERMAN SACRAMENTO MARCH TWENY
FOURTH TWENTY RAMOS MISTER FOR
SECOND THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH PRESS. IMAGES
THERE ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS TODAY ABSENT
TODAY'S ABSENCES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA FOR ILLNESS. THIS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
EMOTIONS. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE. TO
MEMBERS CALDERON EN ROUTE TO T.
TO SPEAK ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY
SIX. TO ALLOW THE FOLLOWING
COMMITTEE. COMMITTEES TO NOTICE
BILLS PENDING REFERRAL FROM
OTHER COMMITTEES. TO ALLOW
HEALTH COMMITTEE TO NOTICE AB
SIXTY ONE GABRIEL. FOR THEIR
HEARING ON APRIL TWENTY SEVEN
PENDING REFERRAL FROM
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE TO ELECT TO
NOTICE THE FOLLOWING BILLS FOR
THEIR APRIL TWENTY FIRST
HEARING. AB FORTY SIX
THREE OF US SPENDING REFERRAL
FROM ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW. EIGHTY
NINE ELEVEN IS THERE IN PENDING
REFERRAL FROM AGING AND LONG
TERM CARE. EIGHTY NINE SEVEN
SEVEN GABRIEL PENDING REFERRAL
FROM HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. AB THIRTEEN FORTY
FIVE WEEKS PENDING REFERRAL AND
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE
AND TO ALLOW TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE TO NOTICE AB SEVEN
NINE FOUR CARILLO FOR THEIR
HEARING ON APRIL TWENTY SIX.
AND THEN RE REFERRAL FROM LABOR
AND EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. MADAM SPEAKER I ALSO
REQUEST PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE REFER
THE FOLLOWING BILLS TO
COMMITTEE AB TWO EIGHTEEN WARD
FROM THE HEALTH COMMITTEE TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
AB THREE TWO SEVEN KILEY FROM
THE PIPE PRIVACY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION COMMITTEE TO THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE AND THEN BACK
TO THE PRIVACY CONSUMER
PROTECTION COMMITTEE. AB FIVE
SIX TWO LOW FROM THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE M. EIGHTY SEVEN
THIRTEEN GARCIA FROM THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE TO THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. A MOVING TO BUSINESS
ON THE DAILY FILE SECOND
READING FILE ITEMS ONE THROUGH
FIFTY SIX CIRCLE RATE. ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE EIGHTY ONE EIGHTY
TWO WITH THE MINISTRY SEVENTY
WITH A MEMBERS TROUBLE FOR THE
MEMBERS THIRTEEN FORTY ONE OF
THE MEMBERS THREE EIGHTY NINE
TWO SEVEN WITH A MEMBERS THREE
NINETY TWO FIVE TWENTY SEVEN
FIVE NINETY NINE WITH IMAGE
THREE. 232-405-2672 SEVENTY ONE
TO SEVENTY SEVEN THROUGH.
TWENTY SIX FIVE FIFTEEN FIVE
EIGHTEEN EIGHT FIFTY FIVE TEN
TEN TO THIRTY TWO TO FORTY SIX
THREE OH FOUR THREE THIRTY TO
THREE FIFTY NINE THREE ONE
THREE TWO FOUR TWO NINE FOUR
THIRTY ONE FOUR THIRTY FIVE.
485-150-4530. TO FIVE FORTY
THREE FIVE SIXTY NINE FIVE
NINETY ONE SIX TWENTY SEVEN SIX
THIRTY EIGHT SIX NINETY SIX
NINETY EIGHT SEVEN POINT
378-481-9830. ONE FIFTY SIX
NINE FOURTEEN TEN THIRTY NINE
THIRTEEN OH FIVE FOURTEEN
SEVENTY SIX FOURTEEN THIRTY
WITHIN MINUTES TEN OH TWO WITH
A MOMENT SEVEN FIFTY TWO WITH
AMENDMENTS. THREE FOR THE
MINUTES AND ASSEMBLY BILL TO
ALSO MEET. WITH A MEMBER. A
BILL TO BE DEEMED READ AND-
DEEMED IT. WILL PASS AND RETAIN
ON FILE ITEMS FIFTY SEVEN
THROUGH FIFTY EIGHT MOVING TO
FILE ITEM FIFTY NINE WE'RE ON
THE THIRD READING FILE MEMBERS
AB TWO FIFTY THREE THE CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
FIFTY THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
PATTERSON AN ACT RELATING TO
ANIMAL WELFARE. MR PATTERSON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THE
MATTER. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER- MEMBERS. ENDING TODAY
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FIFTY THREE
WHICH UPDATES THE PUBLICATION
NOTICE REQUIREMENTS REGARDING
THE SEIZURE AND HE DESTRUCTION
OF ROOSTERS THAT ARE USED IN
COCKFIGHTING. WHEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT APPEARS AT THE
SPIKED IT'S COMMON FOR
ATTENDEES TO FLEE BELIEVE MANY
OF THE BIRDS BEHIND LAW
ENFORCEMENT THEN TAKES
POSSESSION OF THE ANIMALS. AND
FILES A PETITION WITH THE COURT
TO HUMANELY EUTHANIZE THE
BIRDS. THE BEFORE DOING SO
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES A PUBLIC
NOTICE OF DESTRUCTION OF THE
ANIMALS TO BE POSTED IN A HARD
COPY NEWSPAPER FOR THREE
CONSECUTIVE DAYS. AB TWO FIFTY
THREE SEEKS TO UPDATE THE PENAL
CODE SO THAT PUBLIC NOTICES MAY
BE PUBLISHED THROUGH ADDITIONAL
SOURCES RATHER THAN SOLELY
THROUGH A PRINT NEWSPAPER. THIS
ALLOWS THE NOTICES TO BE
PUBLISHED MORE FREQUENTLY MORE
WIDESPREAD AND IN MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES. THE SOURCES INCLUDE
BUT ARE NOT LIMITED TO SOCIAL
MEDIA OUTLETS AND OR ONLINE
PUBLICATIONS THEIR NEWSPAPER
WEBSITES. THIS UPDATE THAT TO
THE CODE WOULD RESULT IN
INCREASED PUBLIC AWARENESS AND
WIDER DISTRIBUTION OF THE
NOTICES AB TWO FIVE THREE IS
IDENTICAL TO LAST SESSIONS AB
THREE ZERO THREE FIVE. WHICH
PASSED OFF THIS FLOORWITH
SEVENTY ONE AYE VOTES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
MR. PATTERSON SEEING IN HERE NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR- ALL
VOTED TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THE. ALL MEMBER THIRTY
DESERVE A. YEAH. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED A.
BURKE WELL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FORTY ONE NO SEVEN THE MEASURE
PASSES. WE WILL TAKE A FILE
ITEM SIXTY AB TWO SIXTY THREE
FOR PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO SIXTY THREE WITH A MINUTES
BY SIMPLY MEMBER ARAMBULA. MR
ARAMBULA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
PURPOSES AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER TODAY I PRESENT
ON AB TWO SIXTY THREE WHICH ARE
AMENDMENTS WHICH WILL TRANSFER
AUTHORSHIP FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BONTA TO MYSELF. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
ON THE AMENDMENTS ALL IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. ALL OPPOSED SAY NO THE
AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED OUT TO PRINT IT BACK TO
FILE. WE WILL PASS AND RETAIN
ON FILE ITEM SIXTY ONE THROUGH
SIXTY THREE. MOVING TO FILE
ITEM SIXTY FOUR AB TWELVE OH
THREE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE OH THREE
BY SIN REMEMBER HER AND I.
ATTACKS. MISTER YOU ARE. OVER
ON THE MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I TO RESUME AB TWELVE
OH THREE IT JUST BILLS. BY THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES THAT WILL
NAY TAX TO JUST BE PROPERTY
ASSESSMENTS ANYMORE. MANNER
SPECIFICALLY TWELVE OH THREE
WOULD EXPAND THE POOL OF
POTENTIAL APPLICANTS FOR THE
SERVICE OF AN APPEALS BOARD. IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY ADDITIONALLY
PERMIT L. A. COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS TO REDUCE THE THREE
YEAR WAITING PERIOD THAT FORMER
ASSESSOR BLAZER SEVENTY TWO
BEFORE L. BEING ELIGIBLE TO
SERVE ON THE BILLBOARD NO LESS
ONE YEAR. I RESPECTFULLY-
REQUEST DR. THANK YOU MISS
pDEBATE THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. HOME
VOTED ARE. TO ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. BURKE WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THOSE
EYES FORTY SIX KNOWS EIGHT THE
MEASURE PASSES WILL PASS A
RETAINER FILE ITEM SIXTY FIVE
THROUGH SEVENTY TWO MOVING THE
FILE ITEM SEVENTY.
THREE AB ONE
OH FOR THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE OH FOUR BY
SOME REMEMBER IN A DALLAS AND
OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
PEOPLE INSTRUCTION IN THE
CLEARLY YOU CAN SEE THERE ARE
PROTECT MEDIALLY. I SEE ARE
RECOGNIZED ANOTHER. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. IN MEMBER. AB
ONE OF FOUR. AIM TO EMPOWER.
THEIR FAMILY WITH OVER. OF
LEARN WE COVER OPPORTUNITY AT
HOLD STUDENTS. FOR THE
CHALLENGES THAT WERE CREATED BY
COVERT NINETEEN. MY KIDS LIKES
MANY OTHERS RETURN TO SCHOOL
THIS YEAR BUT THAT DOESN'T WIPE
AWAY ALL THE ISSUES THEY FACE
WE NEED TO GIVE PARENTS MORE
CHOICES. FOR THINGS LIKE THE
ABILITY TO PETITION FOR GRADE
RETENTION PURSUE CREDIT
RECOVERY OPPORTUNITIES BEYOND A
FORTY YEAR HIGH SCHOOL. TO
PURSUE A PASS NO PASS OPTION
FOR GRADES ATTAINED DURING THE
ACADEMIC YEAR. THIS IS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
GONZALEZ. SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE. MISTER CAR YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I JUST RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL INTO ON A LOT OF
WORK IN A LOT OF WAYS HAVE BEEN
REALLY HELPFUL WHEN I WAS IN
HIGH SCHOOL SO I WOULD HELP MY
GRADE A LOT AS WELL SO THIS IS
A GREAT GOING TO PROCEED TO
BRING FORWARD. THANK YOU MISTER.
FOR SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
WITH THE DOLLARS WOULD YOU LIKE
TO POSE. NOPE THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE RAW. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
TO THEIR TO VOTE. I DON'T THINK
THAT. ALL MEMBERS ARE OF IT.
WHERE WERE HELLO THE ROLE AND
THE I SIXTY KNOWS. THIS MEASURE
PASS ON THE MEASURE I SIXTEEN
KNOW ZERO ON THE URGENCY
MEASURE PASSES. WE WILL PASS
AND RETAIN ON ITEM SEVENTY
MILLION FILE ITEM SEVENTY. E.
C. R. SIXTY TO THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SIXTY TWO BY. VOEPEL
RELATIVE TO VENTURE. MEMBERS MR
VOEPEL YOU ARE ON THE THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER IMPALA. I RISE TO
PRESENT A C. R. SIX TWO WHICH
PROCLAIMS APRIL SIX TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AS HARLEM HELL
FIGHTERS DATA HONORED A THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINTH
REGIMENT THAT FOUGHT IN WORLD
WAR ONE. APRIL SIXTH NINETEEN
SEVENTEEN WAS THE DAY THE
UNITED STATES DECLARED WAR ON
GERMANY. THE THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY NINTH REGIMENT WAS
COMPRISED OF THREE THOUSAND
AFRICAN AMERICAN SOLDIERS
RECRUITED MAINLY FROM HARLEM
NEW YORK. MOST JOINED UP BEFORE
BEING DRAFTED AND WE'RE NOT
ARMY TO FIGHT. WORLD WAR ONE
AFRICAN AMERICAN ARMY UNITS
WERE TO BE USED AS MANUAL LABOR
TROOPS COOKS DRIVERS ETCETERA.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
RESPECTFUL ATTENTION MR VOEPEL
WHEN THE THREE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY NINTH WAS SENT TO FRANCE
IN DECEMBER OF NINETEEN
SEVENTEEN BEING STEVEDORES AND
LABOUR'S PLUS HAVING A RIFLES
TAKEN AWAY WAS THE LAST INSULT
FOR THESE BRAVE FIBERS. PLEASE
GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO MR
VOEPEL. THE THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
NINE THREE SISTER THE ABUSE THE
BRITISH AND FRENCH ALLIES
DIVISION SAID SUFFERED
DEVASTATING CASUALTIES OF
WANTED AMERICAN UNITS ATTACHED
TO THEIR DIVISIONS THE AMERICAN
COMMANDED GENERAL WAS
DETERMINED TO KEEP ALL AMERICAN
UNITS TOGETHER IN ONE AMERICAN
ARMY. THE ONLY KNOWN EXCEPTION
AND YOU GUESSED IT WAS THE
THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINTH
REGIMENT THAT WAS ATTACHED TO
THE FRENCH SIXTEEN THE VISION.
THE FRENCH HEAD HEAD FRENCH
AFRICAN SOLDIERS IN OUR ARMY
FOR OVER SEVENTY YEARS AND THEY
WELCOME THE THREE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY NINTH WITH OPEN ARMS THE
THREE SIXTY NINTH LEARNT
WORKING FRENCH RECEIVED FRENCH
WEAPONS TRAINING AND EQUAL
TREATMENT. THEY ALSO LOVE THEIR
FRENCH WINE RATIONS. THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY NINTH WAS USED BY
THE FRENCH AS A FIRE BRIGADE
BEING SENT WHEREVER THE GERMANS
WERE PUNCHING THROUGH THE
FRENCH LINES WHEN A THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINTH WIN IN
THE BATTLE TO SAVE THE DAY. THE
DESPERATE FRONT SOLDIERS WOULD
CHEER THROW THEIR HELMETS IN
THE AIR AND GAVE THANKS FOR THE
HEROES FROM HARLEM. THE THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY NINE FOUGHT SO
HARD OFTEN AGAINST LONG ODDS
THE GERMANS CALLED ON THE
FIGHTERS FROM HELL THUS THE
HARLEM HELL FIGHTERS WERE BORN
THE HELL FIGHTERS WENT FROM
EXPENDABLE INDIA. AMERICAN ARMY
TO INDISPENSABLE IN THE FRENCH
ARMY. CONSIDER THIS AMAZING
RECORD OF THE HARLEM HELL
FIGHTERS NO AMERICAN UNIT SPEND
AS MUCH TIME UNDER FIRE AS THEY
DID. NO LESS THAN A HUNDRED
NINETY ONE DAYS IN COMBAT THEY
NEVER LOST AN INCH OF GROUND
THE GERMANS NEVER. CAPTURED A.
RATE OF ANY U. S. REGIMENT NONE
DESERTED THE GRATEFUL FRIENDS
BE STOWED THEIR HIGHEST
MILITARY HONOR THE CROIX DE
GUERRE. UPON THE ENTIRE
REGIMENT MANY INDIVIDUALS
RECEIVE THE SECOND HIGHEST
AMERICAN AWARD THE
DISTINGUISHED SERVICE CROSS THE
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY NINE ENDED
UP THE HIGHEST DECORATED US
REGIMENT OF THE WAR. ANOTHER
DISTINGUISHING FEATURE OF THE
HARLEM HELL FIGHTERS WAS THEIR
BAN THE LARGEST AND BEST KNOWN
REGIMENTAL BAND THEY BROUGHT
JAZZ AND RAGTIME TO FRANCE WHEN
A THREE HUNDRED SIXTY NINE
THREE TURNED TO NEW YORK IN
NINETEEN NINETEEN THEY WERE THE
FIRST REGIMENT IN THE VICTORY
PARADE AS VETERANS OF THE GREAT
WAR. COLLEAGUES WE SALUTE THE
BRAVE HEROES OF THE THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY NINTH HARLEM HELL
FIGHTERS I ASKED THE FIRST ROLE
TO BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THIS RESOLUTION. THANK YOU MR
APPEL SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION THIS ROLE IS OPEN
RESOLUTION ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THIRTY VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
WHERE THIS IS HER CO AUTHORS
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE THERE ARE
SIXTY FIVE CO AUTHORS ON ACR
SIXTY TWO WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED SAY NO. THE AYES
HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. WE WILL PASS THE
RETAINER FILE ITEM SEVENTY SIX
THROUGH. EIGHTY ONE. MOVING TO
A VOTE ON TODAY'S CONSENT
CALENDAR FILE ITEMS EIGHTY
EIGHT THROUGH NINETY FOUR. WE
WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEM NINETY AB FOR SEVENTY
SEVEN RUBIO AND FILE ITEM
NINETY ONE AB THIRTEEN NINETY
ONE CHAO DOES ANYONE REMEMBER
WHICH TO REMOVE ANY ADDITIONAL
ITEMS FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND A
CONSENT CALENDAR ASSEMBLY BILL
TEN SEVENTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GALLAGHER AN ACT
RELATING TO TRUST. WELL OPEN
THERE ON THE CONSENT. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED VERY VOTE. WHERE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE THERE ARE SIXTY. SIXTY FOR
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
SIXTY FIVE ZERO. SIX FIVE FIVE
ZERO KNOWS. THE CLERK WILL READ
THE REMAINING ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX I FIFTY
FIVE NO ZERO IMMIGRANT
RESOLUTION THIRTY TO SIXTY FIVE
NO ZERO IMMIGRANT RESOLUTION
FORTY FIVE FIFTY FIVE NO ZERO
IN ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FORTY SEVEN. SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO. MEMBERS WE ARE
NOW MOVING TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. MEMBERS I ASK THE YOUR
TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU MEMBERS THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS ARE GRANTED PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON IN
GERMANY MEMORY. MISTER CALDERON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN IN MEMORY. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY TO TURN IN THE
MEMORY OF ONE INSTIGATE
ATHLETES WHO PASSED AWAY ON
APRIL SIXTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AT THE AGE OF NINETY FIVE. ONE
I WAS BORN IN NINETEEN TWENTY
SIX IN NICARAGUA AND IN
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE AT THE AGE
OF EIGHTEEN MIGRATED TO THE
UNITED STATES IN SEARCH OF A
BETTER LIFE. IN NINETEEN FIFTY
SHE MOVED TO LOS ANGELES WHERE
SHE MET HER LATE HUSBAND. RAHUL
S. FOUR LEASE WHILE TAKING
CITIZENSHIP CLASSES. THE COUPLE
MARRIED IN OCTOBER OF NINETEEN
FIFTY THREE. MISCELLANEOUS AND
ROLL REYES SEVEN CHILDREN IN
THE UNINCORPORATED AREA OF LOW
POINT THERE. WHERE SHE TAUGHT
HER CHILDREN TO GIVE BACK TO
THEIR COMMUNITY AND ALWAYS TO
LOOK OUT FOR ONE ANOTHER. SHE
STRESSED THE IMPORTANCE OF
EDUCATION FOR HER CHILDREN AND
WAS A DEVOUT CATHOLIC. MISSILE
LEASE WORKED HARD TO PROVIDE
FOR HER CHILDREN AND WORKED FOR
OVER TWENTY YEARS ON AN
ASSEMBLY LINE AT MATTEL UNTIL
HER RETIREMENT IN NINETEEN
NINETY ONE. SHE WAS A PROUD
UNION MEMBER WITH THE UNITED
RUBBER WORKERS AND WITH
OUTSPOKEN ABOUT EMPLOYEE
WORKING CONDITIONS. MISSILE
LEASE IS PRECEDED IN DEATH BY
HER BELOVED HUSBAND OF FIFTY
NINE YEARS ROLE WHO IS A PROUD
TEAMSTER AND HER BELOVED
DAUGHTER BEATRICE M. SORLEY'S
WHO SERVED AS A DIRECTOR FOR
HEALTHY COMMUNITIES. AT THE
CALIFORNIA ENDOWMENT. SHE IS
SURVIVED BY HER DAUGHTERS HONOR
FOR LEASE HILDA SOLIS LETITIA
PHILLIES AND IRMA RECALL ON.
HER SON'S ROLE IN VICTOR
FOLEY'S TEN GRANDCHILDREN AND
TWENTY THREE GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN. SHE WILL BE
REMEMBERED FOR HER KINDNESS AND
FIGHTING SPIRIT AND WILL BE
DEEPLY MISSED BY ALL WHO KNEW
HER. THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON
MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS GERMAN
MEMORY THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS MEMBERS I ALSO RISE
TODAY TO JOIN THE REQUEST TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF WANT
TO SUBLEASE. SHE WAS A GREAT
EXAMPLE OF SOMETHING WE OFTEN
PRAISE HERE IN THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR SHE WAS A STRONG
IMMIGRANT WHO MADE CALIFORNIA A
BETTER PLACE. LIKE MANY OTHER
IMMIGRANTS SHE CAME FROM A
COUNTRY DISRUPTED BY
INTERVENTION. AND FOR DECADES
SHE CAME HERE MARRIED ROSALIE
SAID HAD SEVEN CHILDREN WHO
TAUGHT WHO SHE TAUGHT TO LOOK
OUT FOR ONE ANOTHER SHE
BELIEVED THAT WORKERS TO NEED
TO STICK TOGETHER AND LOOK OUT
FOR NOT ONE ANOTHER. ONCE HER
CHILDREN WERE IN SCHOOL SHE
WORKED ON AN ASSEMBLY LINE AND
JOIN THE UNITED RUBBER WORKERS.
SHE WAS COMMITTED TO WHEN SHE
WAS COMMITTED TO WINNING BETTER
WORKING CONDITIONS FOR HER CO
WORKERS. ALTHOUGH SHE HAS
PASSED AWAY THERE IS NO DOUBT
IN OUR MIND SET HER PRINCIPLES
LIVE ON AND HER DAUGHTER HILDA
HER OTHER SURVIVING CHILDREN
OTHER SURVIVING CHILDREN. AND
THE HEARTS OF THE GENERATIONS
THAT FOLLOW HER. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT WE HOLD HER IN OUR
MINDS TODAY AND ADJOURNED IN
HER MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. RIGHT. THIS AMERICAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH COLLEAGUES- I'D LIKE TO
ASK THAT THE ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED
IN MEMORY TODAY OF JEFFREY
FRANKEL. JEFFREY FRANKEL LET'S
JUST THIS PAST NOVEMBER ELECTED
TO THE PALACE VERDES PENINSULA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. BOARD
OF TRUSTEES. HERE DEVOTED
COUNTLESS HOURS IN HIS LIFE TO
SERVE THE PALACE VERDES
COMMUNITY TO SERVE THE SCHOOL
COMMUNITY IN LARGE PART BECAUSE
HE WAS DRIVEN BY HIS PASSION TO
SUPPORT HIS DAUGHTER. HIS
DAUGHTER WHO HAS SPECIAL NEEDS
AND SO HE HAD A SPECIAL PLACE
IN HIS HEART TO NOT ONLY FIGHT
FOR HIS DAUGHTER BUT THE FIGHT
FOR ALL KIDS WITH SPECIAL NEEDS.
V. PALACE VERDES SCHOOL
DISTRICT JUST RECENTLY HAD A
MEMORIAL- MEETING- AND TO
REMEMBER JEFFREY FRANKEL. AND
ONE COMMON THEME THAT CAME OUT
WAS HOW. KIND AND COMPASSIONATE
HE WAS NOT ONLY TO KIDS WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS BUT TO ALL KIDS
THERE WAS AN ISSUE THERE WAS A
PARENT DAY JOIN THE MEETING WHO
TALKED ABOUT HOW MUSLIM KIDS
WERE BEING BULLIED- IN THE IN
THE DISTRICT. AND IT WAS JEFF
FRANKEL WHO TOOK SPECIAL TIME
TO- MEET WITH THESE CHILDREN TO
MEET WITH THESE FAMILIES- TO
MAKE SURE THAT WOULD PUT AN
END. TO THIS KIND OF BULLYING
AND SO. YOU KNOW JEFF WAS JUST
FIFTY EIGHT YEARS OLD HE WAS
JUST SELECTED THE SCHOOL BOARD.
AND HE WAS SUDDENLY TAKEN AWAY.
FROM THE PALACE FOR HIS
COMMUNITY. UGH STARK REMINDER
TO ALL OF US. TO NOT TAKE OUR
TIME. ON THIS EARTH. FOR
GRANTED TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE I
ASK THAT THIS BODY JOURNEY
MEMORY OF JEFF FRANKEL. THANK
YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI MEMBERS
PLEASE BRING THE NAME SUGGESTS
WE PRINT IN THE JOURNAL ALL
REQUEST TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS. FRIDAY
APRIL SIXTEENTH NO FLOOR
SESSION- CHECK IN SESSION
MONDAY APRIL NINETEENTH WORK
SESSION AT ONE PM ALL OTHER
ITEMS REMAINING WE PASSED
RETAINED ALL MOTIONS SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISS REYES MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY
APRIL NINETEENTH AT ONE PM.